تتوالى التحذيرات من تبعات انهيار بنك
وادي السيليكون الذي تعتمد عليه الشركات
الناشئه واغلبها في قطاع البيولوجيا
الحيويه جاءت ابرز التحذيرات قوه باحتمال
حدوث تسريح جماعيه للموظفين في هذه
الشركات التي تعتمد على البنك المنهار
الاصوات كلها تنادي الحكومات بدعم البنك
وتناشد لشراء ديون مجموعه اس في بي
ومحاوله تقليل فرص انتشار الذعر وبالتالي
حصرها سينقذ مستقبل الشركات الشابه
الناشئه جيل كامل سينهار منها ذلك لان
التبعات انهيار بنك وادي السيليكون امتدت
الى بنوك اخرى في الولايات المتحده
وخارجها فهو يعمل في بريطانيا والدنمارك
وكندا والصين والمانيا والهند والسويد
وغيرها ما تسبب في خساره 100 مليار دولار
من عائدات الاسهم محليا واستنزاف 50 مليار
دولار من قيمه البنوك الاوروبيه
اليومين الماضيين وفقا لحسابات رويترز
[موسيقى]